order silk really silver is the weapon
against coronavirus on other strains of
the coronavirus and has been able to
eliminate it within 12 hours
[Music]
jimbacca this televangelist has now been
sued for selling these fake coronavirus
cures fraudsters are wasting no time to
make money from your fear the hoax
likely originated from a white strip
spread belief in Silver's antibacterial
properties some toothbrush brands have
hyped the metal to in order to boost
sales but scientists agree silver has no
effect against the corona virus in fact
exposure to collodial silver can be
toxic times of crisis are always great
times for fake news and propaganda and
the more ridiculous that claims it seems
the more traction they gain on social
media be it tips like drinking alcohol
to kill the virus and fight the disease
as tempting as it may sound for some it
isn't all religious claims that Corona
was a punishment dished out by God or
mother nature our team from DW science
has put together a selection of some of
the most outrageous fake news about
kovat 19 whatever you do don't try this
at home this clip widely shared on
whatsapp is just one example of the many
coronavirus related stories circulating
online the problem as the disease
continues to spread fake news is going
viral too in India a picture purporting
to show an Italian boy taking his life
after all his family members died from
coronavirus went viral but a fact check
revealed that the footage actually shows
the suicide of a woman before the
outbreak and this photo doesn't show
dead bodies on the streets of Italy it's
actually an art installation in Germany
also doing the rounds conspiracy
theories among them but a South Korean
series forecast the corona virus
outbreak back in 2018 just one of many
false stories describing the pandemic as
a premeditated event platforms like
Facebook are rife breeding grounds for
the spread of fake news the social
networking giant is among several
companies pledging to take stronger
action to prevent the spread of
misinformation others too are doing
their bit to make sure people are
getting the right information about
Corona a service called Africa check
recently had to rebuff a South African
mayor's claim that a vaccine against
corona virus had been developed now
while much of Asia
seems just over the hill and most of
Europe is in mid-battle against kovat 19
africa is bracing for impact and fake
news is not helping society is there to
prepare for the onslaught let's bring in
Vincent and Getty he's deputy Kenya
editor at Africa check and joins us from
anaerobic Vincent how much of a problem
is corona fake news in African countries
right now thanks for having coronavirus
misinformation is a big big problem and
the reason is that the more people
believe misinformation
then they will not follow the
instructions not going to wash their
hands they won't practice social
distancing and they will not stay at
home so these things mean that if they
don't pay attention the virus spreads
more and on top of that you have people
trying certain fake cures
or medicines that have been
not to work we've seen in Nigeria for
example that people have been poisoned
by chloroquine because they heard it
could work hmm that means it what's the
weirdest piece of fake news you've come
across so far
well the weirdest I have come across is
that if you take some orange peels and
you boil them and you inhale the steam
you can cure coronavirus and we know
that's not true because your body
temperature internal body temperature
never really changes all you end up
doing is burning and why on earth are
people actually believing this kind of
stuff
well people believe misinformation
particularly about health because it
ties into their yes people are afraid of
diseases that are difficult to cure and
so this gives them hope and when you
give them hope they will try these
figures they will buy medicines fake
medicines if they have to you should
notice that really we don't see a lot of
fake news about a disease like malaria
because we all knew it's curable and the
medicine is clearly accessible do people
across Africa generally trust their
governments to take the right measures
of a false that misinformation are on
fertile ground people are are more or
less trustful of their governments and
the reason they are is because they know
that government really can do the most
to protect them what we have seen is a
bit of dissatisfaction with the measures
that are being taken so for example in
Kenya we know that for example the
number of tests have been rising but
there's a concern that they are not
enough and also the fact that a lot of
people live in an informal economy in
Kenya so they have to go out everyday
and money and it's very difficult to
tell people like that to stay at home
and self isolate unless you're providing
them with money so that they can stay
inside
who benefits from these fake news a lot
of people benefit there are people who
want to grow their influence online and
they'll spread anything that is fake
whether it's about coronavirus or
politics it doesn't matter then there
are people who want to actually make a
business selling fake cures so that you
can actually spend your money to to buy
a fake cure or to do things that are not
true for example orange peel water and
then finally you've got people who want
to drive a political agendas so they're
going to capitalize on people's fears to
spread these stories and that way spread
the agenda that's probably the system is
wrong and therefore you should follow me
because I have the solution so there are
people doing it digitally online we have
technological reasons others have
commercial reasons Vincent and Getty the
deputy Kenya edited Africa Tech thank
you very much for joining us from
Nairobi targeting today our science
correspondent Derek Williams we'll deal
with some of the most violent fate and
false claims about the corona virus
was this virus genetically modified to
be used as a biological weapon this was
one of those conspiracy theories that
was bound to pop up in the midst of a
global pandemic right I mean there have
been too many books and movies with that
as a plot line but a team of researchers
that studied the genetic makeup of the
virus recently published some compelling
arguments for why it wasn't engineered
but must have naturally evolved first
they said Sarris co2 most closely
resembles corona viruses found in bats
that don't cause disease in humans and
of course any evil scientist trying to
build a super bug would have started
with one that's already been proven to
make us sick second in our computer
models the changes to the Stars Cove to
genetic sequence that allowed it to
start infecting us just don't look like
they should work very well they aren't
mutations that any bioengineer would
have chosen if they were trying to build
a super bug because the models would
have said they don't really work so no
the corona virus was not designed by
humans can supplements like fish oil
zinc or vitamins help supplements are an
area nutrition where there's very little
consensus in the scientific community
under ordinary circumstances much less
in the midst of a pandemic the idea that
you can somehow boost your immune system
I mean what does that mean anyway
the answer to this question is a
resounding no the only thing that we
currently think will prevent you from
catching the virus is if you've had it
already and developed antibodies that
will prevent you from getting it again
I'm not saying you should stop taking
your fish oil or your vitamins just
don't expect them to keep you from
catching kovat 19
there is a rumor that loss of smell is a
sign of a severe case of covet 19 can we
hear more about that a recent
large-scale study in Britain that
collected data from hundreds of
thousands of people self reporting on an
app showed that from those who
eventually tested positive for the
disease around 60% had that symptom to a
greater or lesser extent that certainly
sounds pretty convincing the only
problem is that losing the sense of
smell or taste is also closely
associated with other respiratory
infections it's a lot more common than
you might think that's why as of this
morning at least the w-h-o was still
reviewing the issue and hadn't yet
decided to add the loss of smell or
taste to the official list of symptoms
of corona virus infection but that could
very well happen in the coming days if
there is enough evidence to support it
you